what does loving yourself actually mean
it's an ability to be able to walk into
any room exactly as you are being
yourself and leaving that room not
worrying what everyone else thinks of
you because you have this absolute
ability to respect who you are to love
the person that you are to feel proud of
who you are that you are have the
freedom and liberation of being yourself
but further than that is also about
being able to honor where you're at
daytoday it's about being able to
checkon with yourself constantly and
know how you're feeling physically
energetically mentally and offering
yourself what you need whilst also
simultaneously being able to honor where
you want to be tomorrow and it's finding
that amazing
[Music]
balance